my name is Josh spear I'm the chair of
the Global Agenda Council on social
networks our group discussed talked
about debated a lot of different things
around the phenomena of social networks
social networking sites and social media
one of the one of the big ideas that
we're working on is better describing
the shift we've seen from the command
and controls or group group hierarchical
structure of things into a more
networked approach of decision making
and we're applying that to governments
NGOs individuals society and business
and looking at what are the tension
points that happen what are the tension
points that occur when you start to
really dissect what is what is this
social network phenomenon and and how
does it apply how does impact those
specific industries those specific
verticals and if some of the things are
coming up with very interesting some
things like anonymity is is very very
valuable to some people and some
constituents we're on the other side of
the coin anonymity is something that's
very scary and that some people to maybe
governments think shouldn't be allowed
it shouldn't be valuable or valued
online so we're looking and dissecting
and we'll be creating some more work
that will be releasing to the rest of
the form the other teenage things about
the power of the social network
phenomenon thank you